hello there Steve Kaufman here
the linguist on language blogs I haven't
done a video in a while I've been
traveling I was in Europe for a couple
of weeks I got caught there by the ash
cloud as a consequence I had to drive
around from Stockholm to Hamburg from
Hamburg to Vienna but fortunately I was
able to get back on schedule I want to
talk today about grammar a subject that
comes up from time to time you know in
this whole discussion of language
learning we have the output versus input
debate and of course I'm very firmly on
the side of input as the place where I
like to spend most of my time when I'm
learning a language and that primarily
is because I find it effective and yet
very easy to organize although I must
admit now that I've been at my Russian
for a while I find myself wanting to do
more without put I have enough words now
I'm lining up more discussions that link
with our different Russian tutors when I
get my reports back with my mistakes I I
study them and they're fresh in my mind
because I've just finished trying to use
the language use it incorrectly so it
comes a point where you you you
definitely have to speak or write more
I'm too lazy to write but it's good for
it
but for a long while at least in my own
case I'm quite happy to rely on my input
activities to absorb the language now
about grammar where does that fit in now
on my blog the linguist not language
I've suggested that I'd like to do a
little poll amongst my readers to find
out where everyone stands on this issue
I sort of created two fictitious
positions that love the grammar lover
position in the grammar hater position
not love and hate are strong words I
mean the point is you know I want to
find out where people stand on the
importance of grammar in language study
in particular at the beginning
and I think a lot of people I'm part
surprised actually a lot of the people
who have commented that my blog are very
happy with grammar they like grammar
they like the terminology they find it
challenging interesting logical whatever
I don't and but everyone is different
I'm curious to know what what what the
majority of people believe I guess first
of all I have my own reaction to grammar
and and so I'll talk a little bit about
that and then I'll talk about what I
think are the way the ways in which we
learn language at least my understanding
of how the brain works and and try to
justify my somewhat anti grammar
position and in fact we may even have a
debate over at my blog I've asked people
to come forward and and have a debate
with me Vince has come forward but he
doesn't disagree with me that much so
we'll see how how strong a debate we
have I like debate
I like this agreement I think that
debate forces us to think about things
to justify our own positions and also to
listen to contrasting positions not
necessarily with the objective of
arriving at an agreement but simply to
stimulate ourselves and to stimulate
anyone who's listening grammar first of
all I have this tremendous aversion to
unnecessary terminology though even I
get in Russian for example I still don't
understand perfective and imperfective
verbs I understand that the idea of
aspect in other words that depending on
whether something is done regularly or
all the time or continuously or on the
other hand if it's a completed action
you'll have two different forms of the
verb however I have still a lot of
trouble figuring out whether in this
particular instance this is a completed
action or a continuous action and trying
to do it on the fly while speaking I
find extremely difficult and I've read
explanations and they make no impact on
me whatsoever
similarly with the cases there are so
many prepositions in Russia that take
the genitive for no other reason I mean
genitive means of something and yet
probably more prepositions take the
genitive than any other case all the
explanations make no sense some of the
explanations some of the weirdest things
are easiest to understand or at least to
remember like one year takes the
nominative two three four years takes
the genitive singular five and more
takes the genitive plural it's weird but
it's kind of straightforward but there's
so many other cases where are examples
of structures that have evolved a
certain way in a language and all of the
explanations and rules and terminology
don't help much I learned Japanese and
Chinese and I remember in those books
great fixed books de Francis and others
they invented a bunch of new terminology
for Chinese and Japanese I just ignored
it it didn't help me at all all I needed
to know was this is how they say things
in Chinese this is the pattern a few
examples not too many references to
exceptions and I'm off and then I
started looking for it and I see it and
when I see it I try and pay attention
much as I do now in link I will often
save phrases that embody the kinds of
structures that I have trouble with and
so I don't need in my own case you know
I've said that the language is like a
jigsaw puzzle and I just want to get out
the jigsaw puzzle putting the pieces
together and and I don't need a manual
of instructions on the jigsaw puzzle
there are certain basic concepts I guess
at the beginning of a language like this
here the verb comes at the end or at the
beginning or whatever but a lot of the
even for example the idea si in Spanish
that you don't always have to use for
the the the personal pronoun
you start to notice that after a while
and and I do admit that I will sometimes
refer to a grammar book not so much
looking things up but but sort of
leafing through it to see if there's
anything there that that might trigger
something make me more attentive to the
language but I find these terms like
modal's gerron's
I don't know in Korean as I say they
talk about copulative verbs all of this
terminology I am very very allergic to I
just I just resisted and the
explanations my eyes just glaze over but
a lot of the people who commented that
my blog they love like a grammar I think
personally that our brain works best on
all the reading that I've done suggests
that our brain works best at absorbing a
lot of input a lot of experience
stimulus and gradually forming its own
rules that that is more effective than
theoretical explanation of the rules if
I see someone doing something that's
more effective than a theoretical
explanation of how I should do that but
others I gather like grammar is it a
function of the fact that many of the
readers of my blog are linguists in the
sense of having studied linguistics I
don't know I call myself a linguist in
the first sense of the word that I find
in dictionary definitions and that is as
someone who speaks more than one
language but obviously people who have
invested a lot of time and effort into
learning a lot of this terminology once
they've learned it that they find it
useful to apply to each successive
language that they learn yeah I don't I
don't see it and you know the idea that
that the grammar is useful whether we
like it or not someone mentioned
my blog well if we don't like it it's
not useful because when you're learning
something your emotional reaction to
what you're learning whether you like it
or not like whether you like the
language or not whether you like the
content or not whether you like a
certain learning strategy or not all of
these things are very subjective and
your emotional reaction to these things
will influence how useful these things
are and in my case I find grammar not so
useful that's not that I haven't tried I
have studied I have pored over tables
you know I have tried to understand
these explanations of imperfect and
perfect in Ferb's they just don't
penetrate my scalp but I do believe that
with enough exposure paying attention
enjoying the language certain patterns
start slowly to become more and more
natural and that's my take on it you can
also read up the recent thread at the
linguist on language and thank you for
listening bye for now